[MUSIC PLAYING]
CORY O'CONNOR: Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
Thanks for coming.
My name is Cory
O'Connor, and I'm
Product Manager on Android TV
for major platform features,
including the system
UX set up and more.
ISAAC KATZENELSON: Hi,
I'm Isaac Katzenelson,
and I'm the Technical Lead for
the Home Screen and Launcher
experience.
CORY O'CONNOR: So I know
happy hour is coming up
and we'll try to keep
this really interesting,
to the point, and get to
the drinks shortly after.
I'm going to start and give
you all an ecosystem update
and walk through some of
our new announcements.
And then I'm going to
hand it over to Isaac,
and he's going to give you the
technical details about how
you as Android developers
can bring the new experiences
to your apps.
So there are big changes
coming to Android TV.
But before we dive into them,
we wanted to take a little bit
look back this year.
In short, it's been a
great year for Android TV.
We continue to
see amazing growth
in the number of devices.
Our strong partnerships with
pay TV operators and hardware
manufacturers have allowed us
to more than double the number
of devices that have
activated in 2016.
And we actually expect that
to continue, if not increase
in 2017 and going forwards.
We're seeing this growth
both in the set-top box form
factor, which includes streaming
devices and cable and satellite
form factor boxes, and in
addition to the smart TV form
factor.
Since last year at
I/O, we've launched
a number of new
devices with partners,
including the Dish, AirTV with
Dish, the MiBox with Xiaomi,
and with Airtel we actually
launched the first satellite
set-top box based on Android
TV in India this year.
So that's pretty exciting.
The list of partners up
here is actually just a few
that we wanted to call out.
We've also expanded our
international footprint
to 70 countries, and there
are now more than 3,000 apps
on the Play Store.
So that's pretty
exciting, Android TV apps.
In addition, though
mobile viewing has grown,
the TV still dominates
for lean back content.
There's a recent Netflix
report came out shows
that while acquisition
of a user can
happen across a number
of form factors--
that could be laptops,
computers, phones, tablets,
and the TV itself--
67% of long-term viewing
happens on the TV
and in the living room.
Now this just validates
what we've long held,
which is that the
TV app experience is
critical for content providers.
It's what you have
to nail in order
to deliver long-term,
highly satisfied users.
As Dave said in the
keynote this morning,
Android TV has seen
tremendous growth.
I think his stats were a million
new activations every two
months.
But as they say, the
best is yet to come.
So we launched Android
TV three years ago,
and since then
we've learned a lot.
But this year we
took the opportunity
to take a step
back and take stock
of where we were on
the platform, and also
how changes--
to how people were engaging with
content in the living rooms.
Now across the
industry, we found
these three common issues,
these three core needs that
were really going unaddressed.
So the first thing we saw
was that it's really hard
to come to grips with
all the different content
available to us.
So families now have
multiple sources
for what they want to watch
depending on the mood,
the time of day,
who's in the room,
and a bunch of other factors.
And it's interesting
because content
is mostly visible within
the app or service.
So what you do is
you turn on the TV,
and you have to actually
like deep dive into the app
to see if it has
something you're actually
interested in watching.
So it's become really hard
to know what's available
before you figure out who
you want to watch it from,
which we kind of realize is
a bit of a weird situation.
Also, the problem
gets a bit harder
because there are so many
different types of content
available to watch.
Could be video on
demand, and that
could be through a
subscription, paid or rented.
It could be digital, web-driven
sort of social content.
Or it could be live
television through a pay TV
subscription or an antenna
or over the air source.
So as of yet, it's
been really hard
to fold all of these
different types of content
into an empowering
experience for users.
So the second thing we saw
is that the emotional hook
from a piece of content that
we see, it's diminishing.
You can imagine that
we may have found
our way into a list of options.
It could be recommendations
or something like that.
And we're seeing the movie art
or poster art and we're just,
we're not feeling
connected to any of it.
Now with this huge
number of options
for content available
to us, which we love,
we like a big menu, but
we're losing our ability
to make a decision.
Now we saw users
with these huge lists
of options available to them.
Maybe there's a watch
list that they've curated,
or maybe there's recommendations
that they've made sure,
you know, as much as
possible that it reflects
what they want to watch.
But when the time comes to
actually play something off
of that, they really
can't find the spark
that they originally had,
why they put it there
in the first place.
So the watch list
had become more
aspirational than actionable.
The third thing we saw, people
were really looking for ways
to tweak the content on
a device to customize it
for how they want to watch.
So when you bring
a TV into your home
and you sign up for a service or
an app, the shows, the actors,
they become part of your family.
They're part of your routine.
You watch them every night.
It's like a ritual.
We think that part of this
should be being able to nest
with the device, to customize
the experience so that it fits
with your life and your needs.
If you watch people get
a new TV or a new phone,
one of the first things they
do is they sort of move things
around, right?
You move the apps around.
You set the background.
You set your ring tone.
You customize it to how
you want to use the device.
But with TV, from a
content perspective,
people really can't do that.
Now these concerns have
been around for some time.
We're not surfacing these.
These are the only people
to have ever discovered
these things.
But they come out now and again
in user research and market
and analyst reports.
They're known issues.
But what we've done is we've
taken these issues to heart
in Android O, and we've set
out to directly address them
with a major refresh
of Android TV.
Now the first major
change you probably
have already heard about.
Earlier this year, we announced
that the Google Assistant
will be coming to Android TV.
The Google Assistant is
your own personal Google.
You can ask it questions.
You can tell it to do things.
It's always ready
to help, and it's
available across
all of your devices,
so you can integrate
it into your life.
Now what does that
really mean for TV?
Well, one of the core
design principles
in bringing the
assistant to the TV
was that people are
trained from a young age
to talk about media
with others, to use
our voice in the discussion
about what we want to watch
or what we feel.
I do this frequently
with friends and family.
We go back and forth about what
we're interested in, figure out
if it's a show or a movie,
how much time we have left,
what's available to us, and
we arrive at a decision.
This sort of interaction
feels very natural.
It's what we're used
to when we're dealing
with people in everyday life.
Now we think that voice is an
amazing augmentation for media
consumption in the living room.
So what we've done is we've
optimized the assistant on TV
from the ground up
to fill this role.
That means with an Android TV,
you can use the remote alone
to navigate the UI.
You can use the voice
button on the remote
and you'll be able to
talk to the assistant.
Or you can use the assistant
in a hands-free mode
to discover and play content.
Even better, you can transition
between these modes seamlessly.
So whatever you want to do, it
fits the situation you're in.
If you want to talk, it's there.
If not, no big deal.
Now there was a bunch of work
that went into us getting here.
We had to build multiple
speech models, UI that's
responsive to the situation
and context of a user,
and a number of other things.
But what it's resulted in
is a new, more natural,
and transparent way of
interacting with your TV.
In addition, because it's
the same assistant that
connects your Google and third
party services and devices,
you can use it in a bunch
of interesting scenarios.
So actually, let's take
a look at one of these.
Let's imagine it's Friday night
and I'd like to watch a movie.
I might say, show me some
recent action movies.
Now the Google
Assistant knows it's me,
and it knows the
context, where I'm
at, and what sorts of things
I'm interested in, like actors,
for example.
So it's going to bring up a list
of things that might interest
me from multiple sources.
There might be a way to
further refine the search
or broaden it, but
let's assume for now
that I see what I'm looking for.
One thing to note is
that the assistant can
work in a conversational
manner, meaning
that it's going to remember
the context I have in case
there's a follow up request.
So I think I see something
I'm interested this.
In this case, I want to watch
Deadpool, which is a hilarious
movie, by the way.
But if, for example,
it's a complicated title,
or if I'm feeling a
bit lazy, I might just
refer to it by the
order it is in the list,
like I might be talking to
someone else in the room.
So I might say,
play the third one.
Now what's happened is that
the assistant understands
where we're at in
the conversation
and what I'm trying to do.
And so it's going to play
the content that I requested
from the source that I had.
And maybe the movie
is just starting
and the family is sitting
down ready to watch,
and we realize we want to make
the experience a little bit
more comfortable.
So because it's
the assistant, it's
connected to the other
devices in my house
and I can control the
lighting in my living room
just by asking.
So I might say, dim the lights.
And the lights dim, and we're
ready to watch the movie.
Now the second major change.
They say home is
where the heart is.
So in order to truly change
the way people use Android TV,
we had to make a
change to our home.
For Android O, we've redefined
the home screen on Android TV
to be a channel-based,
content first experience.
This new home enables
users to engage
with the content
and apps that they
love all in the same place.
Now instead of showing you
more screen shots up here,
we decided--
at a bit of risk to ourself--
to actually give you a live
demo using a developer device
that we have, and we'll walk
through the features on that.
So could we switch to the
next displayer please?
Isaac's going to
help me out for this.
So I wanted to call
out that we're still
putting the finishing
touches on this experience.
So you should expect to
see further visual changes
and performance improvements
as we move closer to launch.
So let's walk through
the layout a bit.
So at the top, you're going
to see the same quick access
to search that you used to.
And below that, we're
introducing a favorites row
for favorite apps to easily
launch into the favorite apps
right from the
top of the screen.
You'll see watch
next below that.
And we'll come back
to favorite apps
and watch next a
little bit later.
In the middle and
continuing down,
we have a number of
rows full of content
that we call, perhaps
unsurprisingly, channels.
So a row is a channel.
These channels are the core of
the new home screen experience.
Each of these channels
is created by a media app
to display content
relevant to you.
You might think of each
channel as a window
into the content
available inside the app.
Now app surface
content in channels
by displaying programs, which
are the boxes you see here,
with TV shows or movies
or video on them.
So we've got a channel
inside a bunch of boxes.
Those are called programs.
These are recommendations
for content
that's available right
now for you to watch,
and they could be
on-demand content
like a movie a TV series.
Could be a video
clip, live TV show,
could even be a live
traditional TV channel.
And actually there's
a couple more.
Isaac will talk
about that later.
Now each app gets to decide
what the channel is named,
what it looks like, what content
appears in it, what metadata
goes with that content,
and in what order
the content is displayed
in that channel.
When you select a program
that seems interesting to you,
it's going to launch the
app and take you directly
into the content, starting
playback immediately.
If you decide to press the
Back button from there,
the app has the ability to sort
of re-engage you and take you
to a higher level
screen inside the app.
Now by structuring the
experience this way,
what we're allowing apps to
do is surface different types
of content in the
same experience,
giving you the choice of
what you're in the mood for.
Now you could see in the same
experience what's on your DVR,
what movies are recommended
for you to rent,
and what on-demand
shows maybe you haven't
finished binge watching yet.
In addition, apps
have a lot of control
about how they want
to present what they
think is most relevant to you.
So there's a good balance there.
All right, actually, let's
go to the play movies
channel and let's select
"Fantastic Beasts."
Now what you're
seeing right now is
a feature we're really excited
about called video previews.
From our research,
we found that seeing
short previews of the content
has a significant boost
to engagement and decision
making, and that kind of makes
sense.
So lets use "Fantastic
Beasts" as an example.
I know it's set in the
Harry Potter Universe
and I love the Harry
Potter Universe.
And I've seen it come across
my recommendations often,
but I haven't yet, you
know, pulled the trigger.
But when I focus on it in
this discovery experience
and it plays the
preview, I see the world
and I see the characters and I
hear the music and, you know,
it's no longer a poster to me.
I'm drawn in.
Now apps have the ability
to provide video previews
for each program they
put in the channel
regardless of what type
of content that be.
That might take the form of a
live preview for live content.
It might be a trailer for
a movie, for a TV show,
it could be the series
trailer, or it could be--
like a season trailer.
And for video or
digital social content,
it might be maybe
the first 15 seconds
of what that content is.
We think this is going to
drive a lot of engagement
for our app partners and
we're seeing many developers
integrating already.
And you can see it's quite
a compelling experience
as we're in the discovery
mode here over a poster.
So maybe I'm not in the mood for
"Fantastic Beasts" right now.
Let's actually go
to the next one
and take a look at
"Hidden Figures."
So you can see how powerful
these video clips are,
where we're sort of
previewing the content that we
may want to watch right from
the discovery experience.
It's almost like I'm
in the movie theater
and I'm watching the previews
and getting excited about what
I'm about to watch.
Now what happened when--
actually, this looks great,
so let's-- let's open it up
and watch it.
JOHN GLENN: What do
you ladies do for NASA?
KATHERINE G. JOHNSON:
Calculate your trajectories--
CORY O'CONNOR: Now what
happened is we clicked on it,
and it launched directly
into the Play Movies app
and it's playing the content.
This experience
works really well,
you can tell with the
existing app model.
So we've hopped into
the middle of the movie.
Let's pretend for a moment
that I've watch half the show,
but I have to stop and let's
go back out to the Home screen.
And let's go back
to the top please.
So what you're seeing is that
the content has been added
to my Watch Next row, because
I wasn't done with it yet
and the system is
helpfully saying, look,
you have this available
still to watch.
The Watch Next row is a single
system delivered channel that's
always at the top where content
you previously engaged in
will be presented, and
this will be from all apps.
Watch Next is designed
to give you an easy way
to get back to content
that you know and love,
especially if it's
something you're
binge watching or
actively recording
or you haven't finished.
In addition, if you haven't
watched something yet
but you want to
in the future, you
can add it to the Watch
Next row directly.
So I did get excited
about "Fantastic Beasts."
I think it was
the preview video.
So let's go back
to Play Movies row,
let's add it to Watch Next, and
let's go back up to the top.
You can see now how the
Watch Next row over time
is going to reflect the
things that I like to watch.
So an app is not just
restricted from offering
only a single channel.
In fact, it's just
the first channel
from every app that
appears automatically.
Apps can actually offer
multiple channels for a user
to Home screen,
which basically gives
the app more real
estate for them
to draw the user in
with their content.
You know, I wonder if YouTube
actually has an extra channel--
YouTube has lots of
content available,
so let's go take a
look, we're going
to get Customized Channels and
we're going to go to YouTube.
We'll do questions
in a little bit.
So we're seeing
multiple channels here.
You know, today
at the keynote, I
think Sara mentioned that the
YouTube is launching 360 videos
on the TV and Android TV--
we're going to be one of the
first devices to get that.
Well, for a demo,
surprise, surprise,
what a complete coincidence, we
have a channel with 360 video,
so let's enable that.
As you can see, the channel
was added to the Home screen.
So actually, let's check
out one of these videos.
I think we're on a Coachella
video, so let's open that.
Launch the YouTube app.
Now Isaac's going to use
the remote to look around,
and I think this
video is pretty cool.
It's got actually
multiple 360 cameras
all throughout the
audience and on stage.
I think we're going
to do transitions
between these different
cameras, so you can kind of
look around and
see what it would
be like to be on stage, in
the audience, backstage,
a whole bunch of things.
So this video is pretty great.
Let's hop back out, but make
sure to go and check this out
on your Android TV, I
think it's launching
in the next few weeks.
So the ability to have multiple
channels from the same app
and channels from
different apps allows
you to have content for
everyone in your family's case
available from the same UI.
So we've seen how as a user
you can go and proactively
look for channels
available to you
through apps that are already
installed on the device.
Also, though, when
you're in an app,
that app can suggest channels
to add to the home screen.
So a dialog would appear
and you would say yes or no.
And if you said yes, that
new channel would appear.
So in this way, as a
developer, if a user
is interacting with some
specific part, some theme part,
or something relevant for
you to create a channel,
you can actually
proactively suggest, hey,
there's something you can
add to your Home screen
from my app, which
you like to do that?
The last thing we
wanted to mention
is that there's still a
way to access all the apps
on a device, whether
that's because you're
launching an app that
doesn't fit really
well into the MediaFirst
model or because you're just
more comfortable clicking
on icons and brands
and that sort of thing
resonates with you.
So from here, you
can also set which
apps appear in the favorites
row we talked earlier.
So let's go ahead and add
YouTube Kids to the Favorites
row because we have friends
come and stay with us
and it would really
help to have an app that
is very easy for
them to launch, is
very visible for content
available for them.
So it was added up there.
So could we change back
to the slides place?
So in addition to
the Home screen,
we've made changes all around
the Android TV platform,
and we really
don't have the time
to discuss them in this
session, but I just
wanted to pick out two examples.
So as part of Android O, we've
built a completely new setup
experience for the TV
that's going to help you
transition media apps from
other Android TV devices
to your new TV.
During setup, if you, for
example, have an Android phone
with TV relevant
apps on it and you're
signed into a Google account
when you're doing setup
on your TV, we're
going to suggest
installation of these apps.
With a simple click
of a button, we're
going to install the
app in the background,
and that app will
then proactively
put channels full of
content on your Home screen
so that by the time you're
done with setup, voila,
you're going to land
on the Home screen
and it's going to be full
of channels full of content
available to you.
And even better, if
that app integrates
with Smart Lock, what
we're going to do
is we're going to remember
the login information.
So when you click on this app
or click on a piece the content,
it's going to
automatically sign you in.
So you'll get out
of the setup flow,
your TV will have content, you
click on a piece of content,
you go right into watching it.
Also, we've made updates to
components in the Leanback
library and we
call this one out.
This is a great update
to the playback element
that adds detailed
seek thumbnails.
It looks amazing and it's
actually extremely useful
when you're trying
to find something
specific in the scene.
So we talked a little bit
about the three challenges
we saw on the living room when
it comes to entertainment,
and we also talked about the
changes coming to Android TV.
Now with the Assistant,
we're augmenting the remote
to have natural voice
interactions with your TV,
and we're really excited about
the new content first home
experience on the Android TV.
We think you're going to find
that it's easier to figure out
what to watch, it's
more fun to look
at your available
list of options,
and it's more engaging
when you actually
customize this experience
for what you're looking for.
Now, the Assistant will be
available on Android TV devices
back to Marshmallow-- and
it'll be later this year--
and the new Home experience will
be launching on all Android TV
devices when they
upgrade to O, so
expect to see the first devices
with this new experience
late this summer.
Now I'm going to
hand it over to Isaac
like I talked about before.
He's going to talk about the
technical details for how
you as Android developers
can help us create
this experience with your apps.
ISAAC KATZENELSON:
Thank you, Cory.
[APPLAUSE]
ISAAC KATZENELSON: So
let's talk specifics.
What can you, the
app developer, do
to showcase your content, your
app content on the Home screen?
We start with the basics.
We're using two well-known
Android concepts.
The first one is the
content provider.
We use content
providers with new APIs
for storing channel
and programs data.
Your app should insert
channel and program data
into the providers
and the system
will automatically show it.
The other concept is
we're using intent
to tell your app when to
insert your first channel
and when your user is
interacting with your content.
You will use a
broadcast receiver
to listen to this intent
and act upon them.
And of course, to
make it easier,
we provide the support library
for easier implementation.
But what exactly
do you need to do?
What should the app
do and exactly when?
So to better understand it, I'm
introducing Chez Isaac, a brand
new fictional Android TV app.
The app allows users
to watch cooking videos
in different categories,
favorite them, rate them,
and create personal
content channels.
And I will show you what I
did in my app to showcase
my content on the Home screen.
So let's begin.
The first thing
I added to my app
is a broadcast receiver
to listen to this intent,
the initialize_programs intent.
The intent is sent to
your app, to my app
once the app is installed.
So very basically,
broadcast receiver,
they listen to
initialize_program intent.
Once the receiver is
called, I start a job.
I use a job scheduler-- or you
can use Firebase Job Dispatcher
too, it doesn't really matter--
and I insert my channels.
So I decided to insert three
channels, two or three channels
is about the right
number of channels,
I can finetune it later when
I know my users tastes better.
So as you can see,
I schedule using
a job scheduler and a task.
If you notice the 0 on the
setMinimumLatency, when
you set it to 0, it means
that the system will actually
schedule this job
immediately, which
is a good thing because we
need the channel to be visible
immediately after
the app is installed.
The job runs a simple task
that actually pulls data
off my channels from my
back end and insert them
into the provider.
But how do you do that?
So how do you
insert the channel?
So we have, in the
support library,
is several builders
to help you build
channels and programs to
insert them into the provider.
So I use the support
library channel builder
to create a channel,
and you can see,
I set up that type to preview.
I set the display name
to the channel name.
And I set a link back
to my app, so when
the user clicks on the channel
icon, it actually opens my app.
And I use a ContentResolver
to call insert and just insert
the data into the provider.
And the last thing to do
is actually add a logo
to my channel.
So there's a call for that,
and actually, you can either
provide a bitmap,
or if it's too hard,
then you can provide
a URL to the bitmap
somewhere on the internet
and the support app.
It will download it for you
and actually insert it for you.
Same thing for programs.
For each channel, I will use a
builder to insert the programs.
So I set the channel
ID, the same one
that I created before, I
set the type from each clip,
I set the title,
the description,
there's way more
metadata to insert,
I'll talk about
this a bit later.
And then I insert the URI that
will actually when clicking,
will play the content.
Will call my app to
play the content.
And again, I use
the ContentResolver
to insert it into the provider.
And the last thing I need
to do is ask the system
to make the channel visible.
And to do that, I
do one simple call,
I request it to be visible,
browsable, and presto!
That's it.
I created my first channel.
I want to take a moment to
talk about the first channel.
When the app is
installed, it gets
what we called a golden ticket.
The ticket, which
the app can use
to insert the channel
without the user approving.
It will be visible by default.
The app gets a one golden
ticket, so once you
insert the first channel,
this ticket is gone and
cannot be used anymore.
So if you want to add
additional channels,
it needs to be
approved by the user.
So the first thing
you need to do
is do not remove your first
channel, your default channel.
Use it, update it,
but don't remove it.
Since my app shows
video clip, I will use
the program type called Clip.
But there are many other
program types to use
and it depends on
the content that you
showing what types to use.
And each type has a different
metadata associated with it.
The API documentation's
All line show
very well what
exactly the metadata
you need for each clip
type, for each program type.
So just to show, we have
seven type of video programs,
from movies to TV season
and life channels.
And you can understand
that if I use a TV episode,
I may have that episode
number and the season number,
which will not be
relevant to a movie,
so it will use different
metadata for different kinds
of programs.
The same thing
for audio, we have
five types of audio programs.
Talking about metadata,
each app has a title.
It has a description.
It has more metadata,
like the release date,
the length of the program, the
user rating, there's author,
there is price, there's
many more fields available.
And of course, for
the visual part of it,
which is the most
important part,
you can insert two
different images.
One is when the actually
image is focused,
your program is focused
on the Home UI and one,
when it's not focused.
And of course, you can also
use the preview video, which
has the most visual effect.
The more metadata
you add, the better.
So my app is installed
on the device,
the user used it,
watched a few videos,
even added a second channel
using the customize channel
and it's great.
But I want the user
to be engaged more,
I want the user to go back to
my app and watch more content.
So how do I do that?
To do that, I need to
keep my content fresh,
to update my channels
all the time.
So what I did, I
used Cloud Messaging
to have my back end
ping back to my app
when new content is available.
When my app gets this ping, this
message, I run a job-- again,
I run a job in the background
to put this new content
from my back end server, and
also, to query the data that's
actually on the device in the
provider, so I know what's new
and what's already
on the device.
And I'm going to sync, kind of
consolidate the two data sets.
When I do that, I try to do
what I call a smart sync.
So I will compare
the two data sets
and then I will remove all
programs that are not available
anymore, I will add
new ones that are new,
and the ones that are still
there, I can update them.
Maybe the release date changed,
maybe the number of views
changed, I can do that,
update the programs
and also maybe change the
order, because some of them
are more popular than
others and that's OK.
We try to avoid the
remove all/add all concept
or paradigm, because
what happens,
if you do the smart sync,
the visual will be better.
There'll be less visual
glitches, little glitches,
movements on your channel, and
that's what we're aiming for.
So I have more channels, I
have them with fresh new data--
what's next?
So I added a feature into
my app to actually allow
the user to add channels
from the app itself.
So when the user is interested
in a topic or a category,
I pop up a view
which has a button
to suggest the user to add the
channel to the Home screen.
When the user clicks on
it, what I need to do
is a few simple things.
First of all, again, I need
to build a channel to insert,
so I use the Program
Builder to insert
the channels and the
programs into the provider,
and then I do one more
thing is ask the system
to make it visible.
And the way it works
is that I create
an intent, which is
called channel_browsable,
request channel_browsable, then
I do startActivity for example.
This tells the system to
actually show a confirmation
screen.
And remember, the
golden ticket is gone,
you need the user approval,
the user can approve or not.
And when they user
approves it or not,
what it actually know
what the user replied
by checking on
activity result. And I
know if the user
actually approved or not
and do with it what I want.
Woohoo!
Three channels now
on the Home screen.
Good job!
So lets move on.
So another opportunity
to engage the user
is actually the
Watch Next channel.
Remember that was the channel
that was on top of the screen,
and it's a system channel, so
you don't have to create it,
but you do need to follow some
guidelines in order to use it.
So the first thing I
did, I added support
in my app to actually monitor
what's added to the Watch Next
channels.
Every time a program is added
to the Watch Next channels that
is my program, I
want to know about it
and I want to track this.
So it's a very simple API.
You can add, remove, and
check if the program is
in the Watch Next channel.
And you can implement it with
a database or shared prefs--
pretty easy thing to do.
So let's look at some use cases.
So let's talk about
the Continue Playing.
So the user watch
one of my videos,
but didn't finish watching it.
So what do I do?
What I need to do is actually
add a program, like before,
the same concept.
I set that type,
the clip, I edit
another type, which
is what kind of type
is on the Watch Next channel?
This time, it's
Continue Watching,
what we call Continue Here.
And then I add three
more data to it.
One is, when did it happen?
And the other two to
help us with the UI
is, two, the length
of the program
and the current play position.
And again, simply again just
insert it into the provider
and you're done.
And if there's a Keep
on Playing the Content,
I can just update the current
play position to update the UI.
Great.
I have another card in
the Watch Next channel.
One more thing I can do is
that if I have some clips that
are part of a
season or a series,
when the user, say,
is watching episode 2,
I can insert episode 3 and say,
that's the next one to watch.
Or maybe if at the
end of the season
and into the next season, I can
add a card for the next season.
So what I did is actually edit,
again, a program by same type,
clip--
Watch Next is next.
At the top is next,
like next item.
And just adding when
I inserted it in so
it will be in the system.
And again, I have another card
on the Watch Next channel.
The last thing my
app does is actually
listen to the Added
to Watch Next.
As you remember in the demo,
we long press on the program,
click the Add to Watch Next, and
it was added to the Watch Next.
What happened is that the system
actually takes the program
from the apps channel
and copied it over
to the Watch Next channel.
We do that so that the visual
effects will be immediate.
But what we also do is we send
an intent to my app to tell it,
this program was copied and
added to the Watch Next,
and what I did in
my app is, again,
putting a receiver to
listen to these intents.
And thee next thing
I do is start a job
and I save this information
inside my own database.
So when the firmware's updated,
maybe the number views change,
I get a refresh of the
image, I can actually also
update it in the
Watch Next channel
so that content will be fresh.
OK, so let's recap.
What should I add under
the TV [INAUDIBLE]?
So first of all, it needs to add
channel right after install--
at least one.
Keep the channels up to date,
refreshed, engage the user.
Then I can suggest more
channels inside the app.
Use the Watch Next
channel to engage the user
to continue watching
the content.
And listen and react
user interactions.
And of course, do not
remove your first channel.
Thank you for coming
and listening.
If you'd like to learn
more, we have sandbox area,
we're going to see
the demo again.
We have code labs,
you can actually go in
and build your own TV app.
And you can come to the
office hours, I'll be there
and you can ask questions
or you can go online
and see the documentations.
Thank you so much for coming.
[APPLAUSE]